et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis tes
rassemblement national de la somme on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice wesser
Redon du groupe Ebra bonjour Fabrice
bonjour
d'enquête sur les ingérences étrangères
que vous avez vous-même demandé et vous
avez enfin en tout cas le rapport a été
affûté ça on va en parler à charge
contre votre partie courroie de
transmission de la Russie c'est ce qu'il
est dit dans ce rapport est-ce qu'avant
de parler du fond vous êtes piégé
vous-même avec cette commission
d'enquête non pas du tout je c'est très
compliqué parce que bon en tant que
président je ne peux pas parler du fond
jusqu'à ce que le rapport soit rendu
public un rapport de commission
d'enquête entre le moment il est voté
par la commission et le moment il est
rendu public aux journalistes et à nos
concitoyens il est tenu au secret voilà
et le secret c'est pas une anecdote
c'est une loi c'est un loi c'est un
règlement et moi j'ai mis astreint je
commente les filles voilà donc c'est un
peu triste que le rapport est futé que
les rapporteurs redescend s'est fait
beaucoup de politiques politiciennes la
semaine dernière en donnant des
interviews en révélant le contenu de ce
rapport c'est pour ça que j'ai porté
plainte au nom de la commission enquête
pour rupture de ce secret voilà donc non
on n'a pas fait une erreur parce que
vous savez déjà c'est jamais une erreur
de de rendre la vérité publique donc
toutes les auditions sont publiques tous
nos concitoyens ont pu voir que je parle
des auditions qui ont déjà été faites
qui elles sont encore publiques et bien
les services de renseignement dans les
comptes-rendus les institutions comme la
Commission des comptes à haute autorité
pour la transparence disait que on ne
pouvait rien reprocher au rassemblement
national donc comment est-ce qu'on aime
le grip est arrivé à ces déclarations
qui montrait qu'il n'y avait pas
d'ingérence sur le RM d'ailleurs sur les
autres parties non plus à ce qu'elle a
dit sur la courroie de transmission bah
écoutez je le dirai jeudi ou Toulouse je
le dirai plutôt qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve dans ce rapport
rien sans preuve sans payer quelque
chose qu'il a crédit
c'est vrai que c'est sans doute
l'objectif de renaissance c'est de
propager des fausses nouvelles dans le
pays
le fait qu'on peut pas oui oui mais elle
écrit vous savez vous pouvez créer des
bêtises dans la vie on dit qu'il y a une
dizaine de pages là mais sans pouvoir en
rêver le contenu je peux vous dire que
malheureusement je ne pense pas que les
Français soient convaincus parce que je
révélerai jeudi voilà mais là c'est
vraiment je pense c'est pour ça c'est
que non
conférence de presse évidemment pour
pour le montrer si enfin il y a des ce
que sans doute comme des vérifications
pour vous de me recevoir là-dessus aussi
mais vous le savez parce que enchaîne
parlementaire vous savez les limites de
l'exercice mais voilà je le dis je pense
que la vérité éclatera aux yeux tout le
monde et ce sera un peu triste pour la
démocratie parce que vous savez depuis
le début nous a accusé de vouloir
manipuler la commission d'enquête pour
nous blanchir mais c'est grotesques en
tant que président moi je veille à ce
que les travaux se passent bien mais le
rassemblement national n'a que 5 voix
sur 30 dans la Commission les auditions
par exemple c'était les personnes que
l'on invite c'est pas moi qui les ai
décidé c'est toute la commission
d'ailleurs Renaissance a refusé
l'audition de beaucoup de personnalités
liées à son bord à Monsieur Raffarin
monsieur le gaine qui sont très liés à
la Chine monsieur chez nous Emma Bruno
qui sont spécialistes du Qatar des pays
du Golfe vous l'avez
proposé
c'est pas intéressant et que ça rentrait
pas dans nos travaux bon je voulais je
laisse les spectateurs Marine Le Pen il
aurait pu refuser en tout cas on aurait
pu faire une scène si je veux dire pour
la refuser crier à la manipulation nous
ne l'avons pas fait d'autant plus que
les auditions de la commission était
close les commissaires de renaissance ne
souhaitaient pas en Madame Le Pen et
quelques jours après la clôture des
auditions madame le grip est venu me
voir pendant les questions gouvernement
bon bien finalement j'aimerais qu'on
rouvre spécialement les auditions pour
Madame Le Pen ça je peux le dire même Le
Pen a été entendu le mercredi madame le
grip a dû rendre son rapport le jeudi
donc elle a mis que 24 heures pour
intégrer une audition de 4 heures qui
était quand même très dense pour je
pense que vous l'avez vu à son rapport
donc tout ça n'est pas sérieux tout ça
est un peu triste pour l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs je l'avais alerté
madame madame brande Pivet la présidente
de l'Assemblée par un courrier avant
quand j'ai découvert le rapport secret
le lundi sans enlever du contenu
évidemment j'ai alerté la pointe privée
sur sa malhonnêteté sur le fait que ce
rapport ne correspondait pas à nos
travaux madame la Présidente a estimé
d'ailleurs à la raison qu'elle même
n'avait pas accès au rapport ce qui m'a
rassuré sur comme les pratiques de
l'Assemblée qu'elles ne pouvait rien
faire c'est vrai mais au moins je l'ai
prévenu Jean-Philippe Tanguy la
rassemblement national globalement
d'ailleurs les souverainistes Français
n'ont jamais caché leur lien avec la
Russie qu'est-ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui sur ce constat
je comprends ce que vous voulez dire la
difficulté d'utilisation du mot lien
comme l'utilisation du mot proche
c'est-à-dire qu'on utilise des mots qui
veulent tout et rien dire le fait que
les souverainissent Français est
toujours voulu un monde multipolaire le
fait que la France soit une puissance
d'équilibre qu'il soit allié des
États-Unis et de l'OTAN mais pas aligné
oui ça peut entraîner effectivement le
fait qu'on puisse considérer la Russie
le rôle qui doit avoir ou la Chine
d'ailleurs ou d'autres l'Inde moi je
suis président du groupe d'amitié avec
l'Inde nous avons depuis très longtemps
alors que l'Inde n'était pas défendu
dans la diplomatie française considérée
qu'il fallait lui donner un rôle va me
donner un siège au Conseil de sécurité
c'est vrai que nous avons un rapport
différent à l'équilibre du monde mais
c'est pas seulement pour le coup le
rassemble national c'est la tradition
gaulienne l'UMP puis les républicains
ont toujours eu cette position même
l'UDF lui dit a toujours eu cette
position d'équilibre une grande partie
des socialistes avec Monsieur
Chevènement par exemple qui a été
pendant longtemps des recettes lui aussi
était accusé par Satan cette commission
d'être soi-disant de courroie de
transmission alors c'est représentants
spéciales de Monsieur Macron et Monsieur
Hollande en Russie
elle est fille les communistes
évidemment par définition si je veux
dire eux aussi ont toujours été pour un
autre équilibre donc en fait il y a une
grande confusion et c'est triste entre
ce qui redevait relever de l'ingérence
c'est-à-dire le fait que des personnes
ou des parties tous serait de l'argent
ou des avantages pour changer leur
position et ça évidemment il faut
l'identifier le combattre et le condamné
c'était l'objet de la Commission et à
procès politique sur ce qu'est une
politique étrangère une politique
internationale et en fait refuser tout
débat sur la politique étrangère en
symbolisant ses adversaires en disant il
n'y a pas de fumée sans feu voilà bon et
donc c'était l'objet de la commission
moi je trouve qu'on a eu des travaux
intéressants une fois plus on a reçu
tous les services de renseignement le
parquet national financier la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
politique ce n'est pas le rassemblement
national qui nomme les responsables de
ces de ces domaines et donc nous n'avons
pas en ouvrant ces auditions on avait
rien à cacher et si le parquet national
financier avait voulu dire qu'il y avait
un problème avec le rassemblement
national si les services de
renseignement intérieur ou le
contre-espionnage avait voulu dire qu'il
y avait un problème avec le
rassemblement national et bah tous les
Français l'auraient parce que c'est
public et vous nous certifiez vous
pouvez pas rendre public et rapport mais
vous nous certifié qu'il n'y a rien dans
ce rapport qui prouve qu'il y a un lien
entre le rassemblement national et la
Russie bien écoutez ça je ne peux pas le
dire aujourd'hui mais quand vous voyez
toutes les auditions et les comptes
rendus
il y a quelque chose est-ce qu'il y a le
monde il y a aucune révélation
nationale d'ailleurs ça je peux vous le
dire libération qui a fait partie des
médias qui ont eu le rapport en entier
qui l'ont fait écris mot pour mot qu'il
n'y a aucun élément nouveau à charge
contre le rassemblement national aucun
élément nouveau
c'est une façon de ne pas revenir sur
les questions des financements etc le
prêt ou on fait ça
la Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne le président a été auditionné
son auditions et publiques et le
compte-rendu et public il dit mot pour
mot qu'il n'y a aucune ingérence
étrangère dans les prêts qui ont permis
au rassemblement national de contourner
l'omère pas en France il y a quand même
deux parlementaires Julien Baillot et
Stéphane Vegeta Julien Baillot Europe
Écologie Les Verts Stéphane Végéta
Renaissance qui veulent saisir la
justice ils estiment que Marine Le Pen a
amonti pendant son audition auprès du à
propos du prêt justement contracté par
le rassemblement national conduite
c'est pas à propos du prêt c'est à
propos du fait que Madame Le Pen aurait
ignoré qui aurait racheté sa créance et
comment ça s'est faite bon écoutez le
fait que ça aurait été avantageux pour
le rassemblement national
il faut et c'est très intéressant votre
question je remercie en France c'est
très clair aucun parti politique ne peut
percevoir un avantage une entreprise
privée donc d'une banque donc d'une
entreprise comme c'est le cas qui
rachèterait une créance c'est
strictement interdit
aurait été avantagé
la durée vous payez 10 ans en
l'occurrence d'intérêt en plus on se
voit pas très bien en quoi payer 10 ans
d'un terrain en plus à 6%, c'est pas un
prix d'amis est un avantage et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a considéré la
Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne donc si maintenant quand ça
n'avantage pas un certain camp politique
on remet en cause le travail de la
Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne ce qui n'avait jamais été fait
quand même jusqu'à présent qui est une
institution reconnue comme sévère mais
juste à l'international je pense que là
c'est très grave mais c'est parce qu'ils
ont voulu faire c'est qu'en fait en
permanence on veut créer de la confusion
autour du rassemblement national faire
croire aux Français qui a pas de fumer
sans feu et à la fin salir ses
adversaires c'est tristes parce que moi
l'entreprise en de la commission j'ai
refusé d'entendre alors qu'il y avait
des demandes des membres de la nups en
particulier des Verts parce que que je
le pensais qu'il n'y avait pas
d'éléments suffisant pour aller salir
l'honneur de gens et poser des questions
bidons qui visent en fait à interroger
l'intégrité des gens parce que déjà
quand vous recevez quelqu'un pardon en
commission d'enquête en posant des
questions évidemment désagréables et
dures déjà vous mettez en cause son
intégrité parce que certains disent
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là s'il est là
c'est peut-être qu'il a quelque chose à
se reprocher est-ce que vous nous
dites il y a certaines personnes que je
voulais auditionner qui n'ont pas été
est-ce que vous n'avez pas fait une
erreur en voulant présider cette
commission d'enquête et nous en étant le
rapporteur puisque dans le finalement
dans le circuit parlementaire c'est le
rapporteur qui a le pouvoir lors d'une
commission d'enquête est-ce que ça
montre pas votre méconnaissance des
arcanes parlementaires
j'ai entendu cette remarque agréable de
de mes adversaires mais
personne n'aurait donné foi à un rapport
du rassemble national sur ce sujet voilà
donc maintenant il faut arrêter de
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
je pense que s'il m'entendent il
reconnaîtront ma bonne foi personne
n'aurait accepté cela donc je l'ai fait
en connaissance de cause et j'ai aussi
voulu montrer la bonne foi du rastant
National c'est à dire qu'en présidence
cette commission voyant que venait
interrompu personne tout le monde a eu
la liberté de parole à chaque fois
qu'une personnalité liée de près ou de
loin en rassemblant national 4 fois je
me suis déporté et j'ai laissé la
présidence au modem je n'ai comment dire
jamais tenter refuser aucune audition il
y a les auditions que j'ai déconseillées
comme celles de nos collègues de la
nupesse je ne les ai pas refusé j'ai
même trouvé moi-même des numéros de
téléphone pour convoquer des
personnalités du rassemblement social
comme Monsieur chaofocer
l'administration n'arrivait pas à le
trouver c'est moi qui l'ai trouvé c'est
moi qui l'ai appelé devant les
administrateurs pour le faire venir en
commission donc j'ai vraiment voulu
montrer que nous nous étions dans la
transparence et que tout ce qu'on nous
reprochait et était de mauvaise foi
vous l'aviez vu venir je savais que le
rapport de renaissance serait injuste je
ne pensais pas qu'il serait malhonnête
car c'est mon premier mandat peut-être
mais je veux même si c'était mon
cinquième mandat je resterai quelqu'un
qui croit en l'être humain voilà bon ok
même si parfois non c'est pas de la
naïveté c'est que c'est dans l'avion on
fait des choix il y a des choix qui
choisissent des gens qui choisissent de
se fermer à tout et et de toujours être
pessimiste de croire que le pire est
toujours possible il y a des gens comme
moi qui ai fait de préserver non pas une
candeur mais un certain optimiste face à
la nature humaine et même si parfois on
s'en prend plein la gueule et bien
écoutez on se redresse et on combat
voilà moi je suis un combattant et je
pense aussi que les Français vous savez
voit tout vous le savez vous en tant que
journaliste maintenant les Français
voient tout voilà ils sentent tout et
quand les gens sont malhonnêtes et ben
je pense que c'est pas au détriment des
gens nettes et justement vous disiez que
vous allez aller en justice vous
saisissez vous déposer plainte contre
constance le grip traîner une collègue
entre guillemets parlent dentaire en
justice c'est quand même une démarche
bien particulière et là elle use de sa
liberté de parole vous voulez vous qui à
l'instant cette liberté de parole quel
est votre intention en dalle en justice
qu'est-ce que vous espérez de la justice
là moi je n'espère rien vous savez ça va
peut-être faire ricaner dans les rangs
Renaissance moi je crois la vertu
républicaine je pense que nous avons des
lois parce que nous avons des règlements
je pense que les députés les sénateurs
les députés européens les ministres
présents de la République ne sont pas au
dessus des lois donc soit ces lois
existent
du public monsieur mais il y a une
éthique donc il y a une semaine de
secret soit on supprime cette règle et
dans ce cas tout le monde peut parler
soit en la matière on peut pas
considérer qu'on est rapporteurs et
qu'on est le seul d'avoir le texte parce
qu'aujourd'hui madame le grip avec
l'administration sont les seuls à avoir
le texte dans leur main moi je ne l'ai
pas ce texte voilà donc
la justice se fasse moi
sur ce point-là j'ai fait mon travail à
savoir mon rôle pardon la règle a été
enfreinte je le signale au procureur
uniquement sur le le fait qu'elle a
qu'elle aurait parce que voilà qu'elle
aurait dilué le rapport j'estime qu'elle
a non non qu'elle a repu le secret ce
n'est pas de preuve évidemment madame le
grip est origine des fuites dont
j'aurais porté plainte pour cela et j'ai
porté plainte spécifiquement justement
je vais pas vous le faire confusion moi
j'entretiens pas la confusion donc dans
la plainte qui est d'ailleurs publique
qui a été paru dans Le Point que je peux
transmettre à tous les journalistes ma
plainte n'est pas sur les fuites
puisqu'il n'est pas de preuve ma plainte
est sur le fait qu'on aime le grip a
organisé et donner des interviews à
Libération à Sud Radio mais aussi une
vidéo sur le le site du groupe
Renaissance donc ça s'invente pas où
elle explique où elle décrit par le menu
son rapport voilà donc moi je n'ai fait
que réagir aux fuites c'est pas la même
devant qui le procure la procure de la
pépite mais elle est protégée par une
immunité parlementaire qu'on pense
qu'est-ce que vous espérez vous demander
la levée de son nom
donc vous demandez la levée de son
immunité parlementaire
et vous la soupçonnez pas forcément
d'avoir transmis le rapport à la presse
moi je fais pas partie de ces gens qui
essaient de mettre de la confusion et je
sais ce que je sais et je sais ce que je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas qui a fait
fuiter le rapport et je n'ai pas de
raison de croire que Madame le fait et
on rappelle qu'il n'y a aucune preuve
alors qu'il est non mais il y a trois
interviews dans la presse qu'est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres dans ce rapport parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé du RN courroie de
transmission du pouvoir russe qu'est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres parties est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres personnalités politiques qui
sont visées et contre qui il y a eu des
choses qui ont été révélées
malheureusement ça je ne peux pas le
dire aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le droit
de le dire aujourd'hui mais sans nous
dire qu'il y en a
et les auditions sont publiques je pense
que les auditions n'ont pas montré de de
de confusion particulière donc c'est une
commission d'enquête qui fait un peu
petite non vous savez
une commission d'enquête peut montrer
des choses des manquements des choses
graves une commission d'enquête peut
aussi montrer que la République
fonctionne si nos services de
renseignement fonctionnent si la justice
fonctionne s'il ne règle de financement
qui sont très dures en France l'argent
vous savez c'est très bien l'argent en
France ne joue pas le rôle qu'il joue
dans les élections américaines dans les
élections anglaises même dans les
élections allemandes et ben moi je m'en
félicite parce que ça veut dire que tout
le monde peut participer aux élections
avec une certaine égalité si tout le
monde a accès au système bancaire c'est
la seule difficulté mais sans le savait
déjà on va parler d'une autre actualité
l'actualité de la semaine c'est l'examen
à l'Assemblée nationale de la
proposition de la du groupe liotte ce
sera jeudi et hier le décret portant
report de l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
a été publié au Journal officiel la
bataille politique est perdue
Jean-Philippe Tanguy non je ne crois pas
peut-être poétique et permanente je
crois que une fois de plus le
gouvernement s'est pris et majorité
pardon c'est pris dans le tapis en
montrant leur incapacité à supporter le
vote vous savez moi je j'essaie de
refaire un peu le max aussi les
macronistes avaient laissé cette loi
prospérer voter et bien écoutez je pense
que ça n'aura pas fait grand bruit
finalement le fait qu'il les bloqué le
fait qu'il s'est multiplié les démarches
pour nous empêcher une fois plus de
voter à fait que toute la France une
fois plus a vu la nouvelle nature du
macroniste à l'avant on la voyait pas
parce que ils étaient ultra majoritaire
donc leur côté ne se voyait pas
maintenant qu'ils sont minoritaires leur
cette espèce de mélange entre
bureaucratie technocratie et refuse la
démocratie commence vraiment à avoir
beaucoup et saute aux yeux des Français
un mouvement le 6
réussi à le faire oui bah
oui
oui ça je ne peux pas vous dire parce
que j'ai pas vu que je sais qu'on a déjà
déposé une en session ordinaire au
moment de la réforme des retraites donc
je suis pas sûr qu'on en ait le droit à
une autre voilà liote a encore sa
cartouche donc j'ai pas envie de vous
dire une bêtise mais en tout cas si il y
a dépose une motion on la votera et il y
aura pas forcément besoin d'en déposer
une parce qu'elle serait assez
consensuelle c'est-à-dire que la nuit
pêche pourra voter l'iode nous on
pourrait voter Elliot beaucoup de
républicains pourraient le faire aussi
donc je vois pas l'utilité de faire une
notion pour une notion
quel moment national si je dis il y a
pas de vote est-ce que vous continuerez
à siéger comme avant sur les prochains
textes oui parce que nous on est en
représente nos territoires on représente
les Français qui nous ont fait confiance
le fait de boycotter la séance ne serait
pas un problème pour les macronistes bon
il pourrait continuer à faire leur
cirque bon donc nous notre but c'est
d'être là d'être des opposants si le
l'assemblée n'est pas respecté on le
fera savoir on protestera évidemment
très fortement on aura sans doute une
attitude en séance différente c'est à
dire moi c'est vrai que moi je donne
toujours sa chance aux produits si je
peux dire bon avec Madame Board on a vu
si on n'est pas écouté si on est méprisé
le fait d'être toujours aimable va
peut-être aussi changer donc
c'est-à-dire que moi je suis quelqu'un
de gentil mais enfin si on me tape une
fois
plus dur plus
pendant la réforme le silence c'est pas
fini non mais le silence ça c'est une
stratégie parce que si on avait si tout
le monde avait été un peu silencieux on
aurait voté les articles et la réforme
des retraites n'aurait pas été je vous
rappelle que Monsieur Mélenchon pensez
qu'on serait défait qu'on serait battu
sur la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale Marine Le Pen
pensait qu'il y avait une majorité
contre Marine Le Pen avait raison c'est
ce qu'a démontré l'utilisation du 49-3
si Monsieur Mélenchon va eu raison il y
aurait pas eu besoin du 49-3 donc Madame
Le Pen avait raison contre Monsieur
Mélenchon laupes en bloquant le texte à
permis au gouvernement malheureusement
de le faire passer et qu'on ne le batte
pas qu'on ne bat pas la loyal ils ont
une grande responsabilité là-dedans
c'est dommage donc le chahut ça ne sert
jamais à rien ça sert beaucoup les
macronistes par contre est encore plus
dur dans l'opposition bah ça ce sera la
responsabilité une fois de plus des
macronistes qui cherchent le chaos non
leur donnera pas le chaos mais on leur
donnera une sacrée opposition est-ce
qu'à la place des ricoquerel vous
l'auriez déclaré recevable cette
proposition absolument d'ailleurs moi je
j'ai pas de discours j'ai soutenu
monsieur Coquerel au bureau de la
commission des finances je l'ai soutenu
par un courrier je le soutiens
publiquement sur ça d'ailleurs et sur
d'autres domaines où il défend
l'intégrité du du Parlement et pas les
insoumis donc moi là moi j'ai pas sur le
discours évidemment j'ai affronté
monsieur Coquerel pour la présidence de
la commission des finances je le referai
je le referai à jour mais quand un jour
quand parce qu'il va avoir
renouvellement prochaine
dans des magouilles avec la majorité ça
c'est pas mon genre évidemment mais
voilà ça défendrait honnêtement mon mon
rôle de premier parti d'opposition en
fait voilà c'est de désaccord avec
Monsieur Coquerel depuis le début
maintient la note de la France AAA c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour la France oui
c'est tout moi c'est une bonne nouvelle
moi je suis pas la politique du pire
donc une dégradation de la note ça veut
dire à renchérissement de l'endettement
et de la charge de la dette donc moi
j'ai finalement je suis content que les
Français n'aient pas à payer plus
d'intérêt par contre le vrai problème
c'est qu'on part complètement dans le
décor Kevin ma vieux député eren a fait
un très bon rapport en commission des
finances où il expliquait que
l'indexation d'une part considérable de
la dette sur l'inflation alors c'est un
peu technique mais c'est que vous savez
il y avait les taux fixes et taux
variables et bien la macronie a beaucoup
a beaucoup augmenté pardon la part de
dette à taux variable selon l'inflation
donc en inflation explose le coût de la
dette explose c'est plus de 10 milliards
d'euros cette année donc ça c'est une
grave erreur de gestion de la macronie
Bruno Le Maire et de Monsieur Attal
c'est d'avoir exposé notre dette à
l'inflation évidemment nous sommes
contre et j'espère que là on va changer
les titres et qu'on va revenir à des
taux fixes parce que c'est très facile
comme de négocier des taux qui sont
toujours bien meilleur que le marché
merci Jean-Philippe merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin bonne
journée à vous et merci Fabrice à la
semaine prochaine
on va se faire des territoires